what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it looks like we are going to be
getting exactly what we wanted from
Deadpool 3. now Deadpool and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe was already a dream
come true Deadpool coming over from the
fox Universe jumping in and playing with
The Avengers that's what we wanted but
then it was announced that the man the
myth the legend himself Hugh Jackman was
going to be returning to reprise his
role as Wolverine in Deadpool 3. finally
being in a true movie with his best
friend no we do not count X-Men Origins
Wolverine that was not Deadpool but
finally being in a movie with his true
version of Wolverine and Ryan reynolds's
true version of Deadpool the only one we
count and we've heard a lot about what's
going to happen as far as the plot is
concerned of Deadpool 3. and the great
news is we've heard it from Ryan
Reynolds himself this information is
coming straight from him and today's
report is coming from an extremely Solid
Source as well somebody that is going to
be in the movie and this person has
confirmed to us that we are indeed going
to be getting Deadpool versus Wolverine
in Deadpool 3. Deadpool 3 is shaping up
to be a pretty crazy film one that is
kind of exactly what we want yes
Deadpool and Wolverine are going to be
friends this movie is pretty much going
to be Ryan Reynolds hanging out with
Hugh Jackman in pretty much all of its
Glory they love each other but let's
face it Ryan Reynolds kind of bugs Hugh
Jackman on purpose now of course that is
just playful and they really do have a
great relationship with each other but
they do tease each other a lot in fact
most of the promos that we've gotten for
Deadpool 3 so far have pretty much just
been the two of them teasing each other
but today Daniel Stevens who is Hugh
Jackman's stunt double for Deadpool 3
shared a reel on Instagram with a
picture of himself at the gym seemingly
preparing for the role to be Hugh
Jackman stunt double Wolverine and he
captioned this thanks for everything
you've done for my career Ryan Reynolds
but now I'm preparing for your Beating
hashtag team Wolverine
wolverine10 Deadpool 3 stuntman stunt
double dad bod so we get a pretty big
tease here that Wolverine and Deadpool
are going to be going up against each
other and from what we've heard yeah
this is gonna happen like I mentioned we
know quite a bit about the movie now
Ryan Reynolds has described this movie
as sort of a buddy cop film but we also
know that the two of them Deadpool and
Wolverine are going to be traveling the
Multiverse together and what's really
interesting is that Hugh Jackman did
confirm himself that there are indeed
going to be other variants of Wolverine
he's going to be playing variants of
himself so we know that not all
Wolverine variants are probably going to
be as receptive to joining Deadpool as
some others are in fact many people
think that Deadpool is simply going to
kidnap Wolverine from a certain timeline
kind of hold him hostage and take him to
other timelines this is where the
connection to the TVA with Mobius and
Loki season 2 is going to come in and
hopefully we still get Loki season 2
this year more on that in this video in
just a bit because Loki season 2 is
going to tie heavily into Deadpool 3
because these two really are going to be
traveling throughout the entire
Multiverse together now as far as the
fighting is concerned what's interesting
is that Hugh Jackman and Ryan Reynolds
pretty much already teased this and
maybe even gave us a sort of idea of
what this scene is going to be like this
was the second video that they released
teasing us about Deadpool 3 and
Wolverine's return they said we have
questions and they kind of gave us a
little bit of insight on what to expect
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you Kevin feige Love you Kevin
feige I actually think that this could
possibly be an actual scene from the
movie if not definitely some inspiration
from some actual scenes from the movie
it has been confirmed that Deadpool is
indeed going to remain rated R even
though it's over at Disney now both
Disney and Marvel Studios have confirmed
that it is going to be rated R that's
coming directly from Marvel Studios as
president Kevin feige himself so I
myself and I think a lot of fans are
expecting Wolverine to stab Deadpool in
the face Deadpool has already been
stabbed in the face and other Deadpool
movies so I definitely think we should
expect that I am expecting Deadpool to
maybe try to stab Wolverine through the
heart or in the face or something it's a
rated R movie and Deadpool movies are
known for being pretty violent so what
they showed us when they were kind of
fake fighting with each other could be
adapted into the actual movie now as far
as the actual plot of the movie is
concerned what is actually going to be
happening is Deadpool and Wolverine like
I mentioned are going to be going
through the Multiverse but the really
cool thing is well two things here one
is that the TVA and specifically Mobius
are going to be chasing Deadpool and
Wolverine as they Multiverse travel we
are expecting something along the lines
of this to be addressed in Loki season
2. or at least lead into what Deadpool 3
could possibly be about we are expecting
a little hint possibly a little warning
that someone's gone off the map or sir
it's that Deadpool guy again something
like that a little teaser in Loki season
2 but when we finally get into Deadpool
3 Deadpool is really going to be messing
up the Multiverse because we've heard
from several sources at this point in
time Deadpool is visiting multiple
universes and in those universes are
going to be multiple variants of the
X-Men the Fantastic Four and of course
probably fingers crossed here The
Avengers from what we've heard Kevin
foggy does indeed want the original Fox
X-Men back along with other older
pre-marvel Cinematic Universe characters
of course but specifically the X-Men
because that's where he started off at
so he wants them in not only Deadpool 3
3 but Avengers Secret Wars he wants to
say goodbye in secret Wars but he wants
to bring them kind of into the picture
with Deadpool 3. we've also gotten
reports from insiders in the past
stating that the original Fantastic Four
might even show up and Hugh Jackman
himself has even teased that he's going
to have a dual role and he's teased that
this movie he's going to be doing
something that he's never done before he
said in an interview when I keep
thinking of me and Ryan of Deadpool and
Wolverine which are classic comic book
Rivals there's also a dynamic that I've
never really got to do before as
Wolverine I just thought this is gonna
be fun something I've never done before
I can't wait and what most people
believe that he is referring to is kind
of the whole comedy thing when he's
Wolverine he's typically very very
serious of course he's got some funny
moments but overall the X-Men movies
aren't comedies and Wolverine is a very
serious character so really something
that he's never got to do before as
Wolverine is two things one he's never
really got to explore that comedy aspect
to the character and a relationship with
Deadpool and two he's never been in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe which is what
we believe he is partially referring to
here and what he is really looking
forward to in fact many of the old X-Men
actors had said that they wish they
could have been a part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe now of course with
the first X-Men films it didn't exist
but now with Deadpool 3 they're kind of
getting their chance to play different
variants of each other and Hugh Jackman
said yes it will even be a dual role
Ryan and I have been friends for 20
years we have a lot of fun together we
are filming this Summer that dual role
we believe is him playing a different
variant of himself possibly wearing a
classic Wolverine suit as well because
he teased that classic Wolverine suit
some time ago when bosslogic posted a
picture of the classic helmet and Hugh
Jackman posted that as well teasing that
we could finally get that yellow and
blue suited Wolverine with the ears and
everything fingers crossed that either
him M or the variant that he is playing
rocks that suit at some point in time in
the movie either way Deadpool 3 is
already shaping up to be a phenomenal
movie we've got violence we've got
fighting between Deadpool and Wolverine
we've got comedy between Deadpool and
Wolverine we've got Deadpool pissing
Wolverine off the TV8 and Mobius are
going to be hunting them down the entire
time and they're going to explore the
Multiverse scene old X-Men characters
old Fantastic Four characters this movie
should be perfect hopefully it is
executed the right way but hey let us
know what you think about this in the
comments down below are you excited for
Deadpool 3 with Ryan Reynolds and Hugh
Jackman returning as Wolverine leave
your thoughts in the comments down below
please don't forget to like the video
and subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest Marvel news of course
you can always follow us on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching wolf wolf
baby